here's a story that uh caught my
attention from the post-millennial and
um reading now the article the B
Administration has issued a new uh
issued new federal regulations that
mandate museums to get consent from
Native American groups before displaying
or performing research on cultural items
the New York Times reports that the rule
is part of the National Park Service new
regulations for the Native American
Graves and repatriation act and provide
a step-by-step road map with specific
timelines for museums and federal
agencies to facilitate disposition or
repatriation these regulations have
caused the Museum of Natural History
founded by President Teddy Roosevelt to
close two major exhibit Halls that house
Native American artifacts and objects on
the Eastern woodlands and the Great
Plains the new rules offer systematic
processes through which museums and
federal agencies must defer to the
Native American traditional knowledge of
lineal descendants Indian tribes and
native Hawaiian organizations this went
into effect on January 12th so it just
went into effect in taking the DraStic
action Museum president sha Deer uh sent
a letter to staff explaining why that
research and information would no longer
be available to museum
visitors quote the Halls were closing
are artifacts of an era when museums
such as ours did not respect the values
perspectives and indeed shared Humanity
of indigenous peoples actions that may
feel sudden to some may seem long
overdue to others 10,000 feet of
exhibition space will be closed to the
public because of this plan to stop
showing Native American art an artifact
out of concern that sharing the history
of Native Americans would be offensive
to Native Americans theor said that that
some objects may never come back on
display but he said That Others May
after they get clearance from the Native
Americans or whatever let's just let's
just track this let's let's go through
the timeline here okay it's so it began
with the mascots right we're told that
we can't use native American imagery or
mascots uh or or references or names or
whatever for for sports teams because
that's offensive to Native Americans
somehow we need their permission right
we need we need their permission to have
um mascots that have something to do
with Native Americans now we still have
not applied that to anybody else
nobody's asked for my permission as a
person of Irish
descent uh for Notre Dame to continue
calling itself the Fighting Irish and to
have the drunken leprechaun uh Irish guy
m Scot nobody's asked me about Lucky
Charms no one's asked me about that as
far as I know nobody's consulted any
person of Irish descent about that um so
Native Americans are are they're special
you know they're put in a special
category and uh we we need to treat them
with kid gloves and and something that
is fine for everybody else is not okay
for them because because of how special
they are um so we ended up getting rid
of of most of those mascots and team
names okay
and notice every step along the way as
always they say that well it's just this
this is all we're going to do you know
we just want to get rid of the mascots
it's offensive and then we'll stop
that's it it's just that's all we got to
do so like don't make a big deal out of
it they want to change Redskins because
it's offensive and they want to call it
something else uh they want to change it
to the lamest name ever conceived it's
fine but don't make a big deal because
it's just that it's just a mascot what
do you care about the mascot so
much well then they quickly moved over
to other depictions of native Americans
we had to take the native woman off of
the Lando Lakes box of butter like we
had to get rid of native
imagery in in all of these kind of
commercial areas e even where it's not
cartoonish or funny it's not supposed to
be a
joke land Lakes butter was it was
literally just a depiction of a Native
American woman just like sitting there
there was nothing offensive about it it
wasn't cartoonish it wasn't a
caricature but even even there just the
depiction itself is
offensive now I want you to think about
this for a second
okay where else have you heard of
anything like this where it's now
offensive to simply just depict in any
context uh someone else really this is
we have turned Native Americans into
these like deity likee
creatures so we we are adopting the same
reverence for Native Americans that
Muslims have for the prophet Muhammad so
it's just like in Islam you don't there
are no depictions of the Prophet
Muhammad it it's we're doing the same
thing with Native Americans there are no
depictions we can't you can't depict
them these are sacred these are sacred
beings these are sacred beings and and
to depict them at all is is a is Crash
and
exploitative well does that apply to
like other people well no so okay so you
you can't have the Native American on
the butter box but you can have anybody
like if it was just a white woman it'd
be
fine oh yeah of course but why is that
fine I thought you just said it's
exploitation so it's only exploitation
for them because they're special you see
and that was all bad enough but but that
you know uh of course the left argued
that's it that's all we're doing you
know you can't do mascots we're not
going to really explain why it doesn't
make sense uh you can't have them in any
kind of commercial
depiction again we can't explain why but
just go with us we stopped there that's
it that's the end of it okay well now
we've moved to mum exhibits okay now
they're saying you can't even have
Native American references and
depictions and artifacts in
museums the one place where they always
said well of course there of course
there obviously it's not like we're
going to start taking them out of
museums well now they're taking them out
of museums
too like these are places that exist to
preserve
history and somehow to preserve the
history of native societies is offensive
to them or at least we need to get their
permission whose permission exactly
whose permission are we getting tell me
what special communal board or
individual decides whether they talked
about the Great Planes uh so the Great
Planes artifacts can't be
displayed and again by the way so we're
not just talking about like you go to
the Smithsonian and they have uh they
have they have you know wax figures and
that sort of thing and these these
displays of of native they're not just
saying you can't have that because
that'd be crazy enough they're saying
just artifacts like if there was a an
arrowhead that that 180 year old
arrowhead from that they from the
kamanche tribe that they found on the
Great Planes you can't even show
that why because he didn't get get
permission from who from the guy who
died 180 years ago whose Arrowhead it
was whose permission are you asking well
you got to get permission from some
native
person who these are so we gota so you
got to find some uh some
woman working in a cubicle some like
middle-aged woman working in a cub
cubicle in Iowa somewhere with Native
ancestry she's a we had get her
permission who the hell cares about her
permission she doesn't own it she has no
relationship to it now if you have a
family
heirloom in your house that has been
passed down through the generations yes
you own that and I would be very much
against Museum the Smithsonian barging
into your home and taking your family
airlo I'd be very opposed to
it but these that's not what these are
these are artifacts that have been found
and they've been given to the museum and
now it's like we're saying that random
people because they can supposedly Trace
their Heritage back
to people related to that or they get to
decide if anyone gets to look at it okay
um and aside from the question of
ownership since when do we allow ethnic
groups to have absolute say on how their
own history is told and I asked that
question in these days I think the
question itself will seem like absurd to
some very stupid people because they'll
say well of course we should have let
them this no
that's not how it works history is not
owned okay you don't own the history of
your own ethnicity you don't own that
it's a thing that happened you don't get
to take ownership of it anyone else can
talk about it they can write about it
they can give their own perspective on
it they can research it it's not an
object that you own you
lunatics whatever happened
happened okay the the nobody owns
history you don't get to decide what we
say about it or remember about it or
what artifacts we get to look at just
because you had an ancestor 200 years
ago tied to that history
supposedly and the Really absurd thing
is you know they usually say this the
the uh as the saying usually goes that
the winner gets to write the history
book right well we have flipped that
completely on its head because the
Indian tribes lost they lost the Indian
Wars I mean they lost one battle after
another just nothing but taking lves
frankly like it was hundreds of years of
losing and and they were conquered and
they lost and now we've decided that the
losers get to have total
control over how their own history is
told that this is the price we're
supposed to pay for the unforgivable
white sin of bringing civilization to
the new world the unforg because we were
supposed to be pleading forgiveness for
the fact that we don't all currently
live in a world that's 3,000 years in
the past that people are still getting
scalped right and your mother and your
daughter could be could be kidnapped and
enslaved by a raiding party at any time
because that's the world that the
Indians all lived in every single one of
them every single one of them okay lived
in a violent brutal warfaring
Society um and our great sin is making
sure that we don't live in that world
anymore like the fact that we that we
all live in a world that none of us
would want to live in none of us would
want that okay and so we're supposed to
um be be uh distraught with with with
guilt over that the sin that Western
Civilization committed by not holding
itself back and leaving this entire
hemisphere alone forever I mean this
entire hemisphere spere was about 5,000
years in the past it was living about
5,000 years
behind pretty much the whole rest of the
world and the implication is that the
whole rest of the world was supposed to
just kind of sit there and wait so hang
on guys let's let we'll let them catch
up no no no don't go over there don't no
don't that whole whole thing they don't
they own all of it everything on that
side of the Atlantic they own everything
we can't go over there the whole thing
uh they're about 5,000 years behind the
about 5,000 years they'll catch up
they'll be fine that's what people that
that is basically the claim now and it's
so crazy that you you can't
even hardly put it into words even
though I've been putting into words for
a long time uh so and now for that sin
we've lost the right to look at Indian
artifacts in
museums
um you know and the last thing that I'll
say here is that
if there are artifacts or
exhibits that deal with a certain ethnic
group and the people in that ethnic
group don't want us to see it that's all
the more reason why we
should because it's like not only should
we not give ethnic groups like The veto
power over what museums say about them
and their history but actually if they
want to V tell it that's all the more
reason why like that's the most
important thing we should see in the
museum
actually so if there are Indian groups
coming in and saying oh no no we don't
want that you can't that you can't show
that that we can't no everyone needs to
see that whatever it is like whatever it
is you're embarrassed about we should
all see it because you don't get to do
that you don't get to go in selectively
and say I don't like that part of our
history you're you're not allowed to
talk about that
now and of course the ultimate effect
here ironically is that native Americans
are just being completely
erased while we hear so much about
representation and visibility we're
actually simply erasing Native Americans
from the culture completely and we're
doing it at the best of Native American
activists who are asking to be
erased think about it a decade ago right
a decade
ago Indians were like a hundred times
more visible in our culture than they
are today it took this age of
representation and visibility to make
them
invisible and to do all of that again in
the name of Tolerance tolerance for the
very people whose likeness and history
we are throwing into a giant black hole
to be eradicated and
forgotten it is
uh
amazing and of course I say all that
with a certain amount of uh willful
naive because what I actually realize is
happening is that they're not just
erasing the history and then leaving a
blank
space no the point of erasing it and not
letting us talk about it or see it or
see it in a museum is so that you can
then
recreate a different history so the
whole like the noble savage myth this
this sort of like idea of
natives that you find in the Pocahontas
movie in the 90s right totally a total
cartoon no bearing on reality but that's
what they want they want to create
that so I know what they're embarrassed
about the museums like all evidence
that this was a primitive
violent uh world when it was dominated
by native tribes they don't want any
evidence of that they don't want you to
know that you're not supposed to know
that and they want to get rid of all
that if You' like to see what else I
have to say you can access my full show
by going to dailywire.com or by going to
the Matt wall Show Twitter page hope to
see you there godp speed